thousands of people who got a
telemarketing call for Dish Network in
2010 or 2011 may be able to collect
$1,200 per call now if you think that
sounds too good to be true you're not
alone lawyers say they're having trouble
convincing people to sign up to get the
money they're owed from the 61 million
dollar class-action lawsuit it's over
sales pitches to people on the National
Do Not Call Registry there's been a 120
percent increase in complaints about
violations of the list since 2014 Anna
Werner has been following this story and
a good morning good morning Nora and yes
nearly 230 million people numbers that
is are on the Do Not Call Registry it's
supposed to stop unwanted telemarketing
but it has not thousands are now
eligible for pay back after a lawsuit
against DISH Network yet some aren't
buying what the lawyers are selling when
someone is on the Do Not Call list it
means do not call but telemarketers did
call Debra Turner I wanted to do sue to
the latest from Dish salespeople for
Dish Network allegedly dialed the
Chicago banker fifteen times in 2010 and
2011 asking her to sign up for their
satellite TV service
it's a continue to call and continue to
call and you're giving that same
information for me I'm not interested in
changing then it became annoying so when
she got another call recently from a man
telling her she could receive up to 18
thousand dollars through a class-action
lawsuit yeah right is my first thought
right attorney John Barrett is hearing
that a lot as he tries to contact a
group of people who may be eligible for
thousands of dollars each talking to
them firsthand I learned that they
thought that we were a telemarketers or
be trying to scam them some won't answer
others hang up on him that's despite the
fact he did win a lawsuit against DISH
Network for what a jury found was
illegal telemarketing you went after the
telemarketers but now these people think
you're another telemarketer I nobody
gets money for free right that's the you
must be a scam that's kind of what a lot
of these people were thinking but it's
no scam the
jury awarded $400 for each of the 51,000
calls made in violation of the Do Not
Call Registry not only that a judge
later determined dish willfully and
knowingly violated the law and tripled
the damages to $1200 per call the
evidence was that Dish Network knew what
was going on had the ability to put an
end to it but didn't dish is appealing
the ruling the company blames an outside
contractor which has since shut down
telling CBS News these calls violated
dishes Express instructions to the
contractor as the appeals process plays
out and Turner waits for her money I
have bills to pay I have a mortgage
Barrett is hoping more people pick up
the phone to join in we have an
obligation to be standing up on the
mountaintops shouting about the result
that we got in this lawsuit to try to
reach the people that need to be reached
well this lawsuit is in addition to a
separate government case in which a
court ordered Tish to pay a 280 million
dollar penalty now to see if your phone
number received one of these calls you
can visit cBS This Morning Calm I have
to warn you however though although
there are thousands of people nationwide
punching your numbers in is a bit like
the lottery you should definitely go try
it and see you go to our website we've
posted the link all right and see if
your number or numbers are up there how
many of your old numbers did you punch
every single squad and when you do so
just say daddy needs a new pair of shoes
if it'll work tomorrow you know I got
paid thank you very much